okay God okay start okay so as if
Jurassic Park didn't cement you on not
wanting to clone don't clone dinosaurs
apparently don't clone people either
because they'll bring about the end of
the world yeah because you know clone
people and cloned dinosaurs same thing
it turned into this weird Southern
gothic novel with the creepy old house
and the secrets in every corner and then
the girl finds out that there's been the
secret from the start goddamn secret the
little girl is a clone and it literally
had all this change of James everywhere
it's like you know this is a good enough
time as any to tell you you're a clone
of James cromwell's like daughter and
light and then the reveal was so stupid
so I haven't figured it out yet don't
you know who she is
well I'm like I didn't I mean I guess in
retrospect they had that clue with the
picture but I didn't know what the hell
I was looking at no at that picture I'm
like I figured like Oh like at first I
thought so cuz I couldn't tell because
it looked like the maid only she looked
younger yeah it should be a minute to
play cuz that first was a James Cromwell
banged the maid was like wait but that
girl pip and she looks way younger
and this maids and really old dunno
whatever she is like doc villain comes
in while all these die sets are at Ang's
like give me my daughter give me my
daughter why cuz she's a clone you
figure it out she's a clone and it's
like she's right there hearing this so
and it's like he's at least at this
kid's gonna need so much there's at
least attempting early on to be like
okay I'm sorry honey I'll be down soon
like Wally's trying to get these
dinosaurs everything so it's like okay
there's some attempt to be a parent and
it's just like who would just do that
you know he talks like anyone would talk
it's all exposition like is everything
his exposition talk is said is he her
like I couldn't figure out his
connection to this guy see the breath is
he the son-in-law or is he what was the
connection he's at least
enough to receive is she in this hunting
it like you're like a business no no
kiss he's saying lot Locker in the room
yeah while they do the auction again
just like why did you do it there again
uh you know why did you send her
somewhere else
it's your to logic
the little girl walks out and discovers
the secret hidden in the basement
because of course the evil plans are all
happening in the basement yeah why did
you have your little kid in the safe
houses dinosaur yeah no a what are you
time to swords in your house this is no
reason where the guy can find out any
second and does yeah no you you go call
the police and tell on yourself I mean
what's with the pillows I love this
suffocating pillow looks pretty nice
well I'll give it a try and and I'll
tell you I feel I feel like there is an
opportunity missed cuz like that's the
other problem this weed advertises
everything it does like he picks up the
pillow and then goes and it has like the
common decency not to show you what he
does the music just goes don't don't
don't
and a little moves out and I'm just like
it would have been way career it's like
you need to talk to him now and like he
just goes in the door and and says like
yes sir and then the next time you see
anything is when the girl walks into
grandpa's dead and there's a good like a
pillow on the side and she puts it
together as I've been way creepier no
but that was actually a really creepy it
advertises like everything looks like
snow cuz and that's it's a problem
mostly with the whole movie said there's
never any suspense cuz they show you
what's happened already explain
everything to like nobody's an eels that
girl comes in and you already know like
well grandpa's dead because we know what
he did even though they didn't show you
him Angela it's just oh I forgot to say
this to fuckin Chris Pratt and the
Howard are split up they do the
Ghostbusters two things that's what they
can get back together and they do that
stupid twister shit where all they do is
argue and it's like I don't want to see
them together
they've become kind of annoying and
obnoxious so this guy's just like yeah
she's a clone because his daughter
originally died and so he he brought her
back and she's a clone and I'm like why
what who
cares why the fuck was this even and
then you find out the ages week a stupid
terrible reason why which justifies
nothing and brings about pretty much the
end of the world it's okay so the
dinosaurs are all of a like that this
gas is gonna kill them all and they let
him out the cages but but the door is
still the doors gonna lead them to you
know of course Dallas yeah
sits there and is like ready the puts
like Brendan to me
don't push it it's a history eraser but
you fool okay and Chris Pratt is like
dude if you do that there's no going
back
raise the idiot that is a very good
point but not only that let's just talk
about the fact that the one guy who
would have any emotional connection to
these dinosaurs she doesn't like she did
they're just dinosaurs it's the kinda
the same whenever he has a connection to
blue and into these things these reefs
even he's just like don't you fucking
dare yeah like this is this is crazy
town and I don't see and so all of a
sudden they make it look like she's
gonna push ease and I was yeah I was
watching that and I was just like you
can't be fucking serious and then he
closes and I was like okay I'll give a
crap this nobody I knew malls here
something but then the kid goes oh the
world and her weak ass dumb are you
fucking kidding me excuses they're alive
like me and I'm like yeah and guess what
look at kill a bunch of little kids like
you like you little dumbass idiot who
brought about the end of the world I
just literally shout it are you crazy
bitch I think somebody turned around and
looked like are you kidding me like I
can't
no no so now there's again the last band
of this movie what the film should have
been just dinosaurs
muck on the earth yeah that's what this
movie should have been yeah they were so
Rama Singh at the end of the other one
so it's like why do we just have the
last minute is the movie we wanted to
see which even then lost world kind of
did with the t-rex but but it's only the
t-rex it's like I get it upping the ante
having the other dinosaurs go out there
and see what happens having people
trying to capture them and stuff you
know could be interesting but it's like
no we get them the last minute and is
for that stupidest reason even though
there was the most perfect set up from
the last film to let it happen nothing
in this film needed to be it was all
these steps backwards and not
interesting not fun and none of it
needed to be I just was if you go eat
people in suburbia or in the city if you
can't bring anything new to the table
then don't do it yeah like and that's
what this movie the most newest thing
was the one bad chick and I was like it
was just so crazy that my job dog was
like she's a clone
that's why Hammonds you know and this
guy split up cuz he closed his I'm just
like well that's crazy but that was the
only new thing and that's the difference
between this and dress I was like I like
dressing well it gave me something new I
got to see the park and as dumb as it
was it certainly was like he gave me new
things to look at and this like it
ripped off Jurassic world it ripped off
Jurassic Park through the lost world and
ripped off Jurassic Park I'm right down
to her in the freaking dumbwaiter with
the dirtiest kitchen scene the grommet
seeing the brontosaurus you know like
all these scenes from like okay well
that's from lost world that's from
Jurassic Park that's from that's from
Gasing world I mean like everything on
that film that's one that barely a
single original idea even are just bad
shit yeah and then the whole climb it
was so anticlimactic where the thing
hops up on the glass roof and with the
second breaking glass the breaking yeah
world the breaking glass when they got
up on the breaking glass it just
suddenly hit me I'm like shit and
because it had that see where it shows
that the dinosaur bones below poking up
like in the it's am again advertising
exactly what's going or they're gonna
make it fall and that's gonna land on
the the dinosaur bones because this
filmmaker can't get away without just
telling you what's gonna happen
minutes ahead of time so and when
they're up there on the glass it was
like holy crap
this is it this is gonna be the big
climax after that huge volcano in the
beginning and then the prams like fallen
Kingdom and Jurassic world maybe we're
gonna have dinosaurs run amok on the
earth and then they're now on the
continent this is it and like that like
literally I sank into my seat and like
took my glasses off and just rubbed my
eyes so disappointed like the physic
part moves like I could barely even
watch it I just didn't even want to
watch I'm like this is just it's all the
same thing all over again and this is
what they're gonna hinge on and then
they're just like oh we're gonna be
extra cute though
because this time word for it the
Raptors gonna jump on top of the
dinosaur bones and do the t-rex in the
back see see tickets again for Jurassic
Park you can literally do a count of how
many scenes just rip off from the other
movies but not like in a clever way it's
just like well they did it so we can do
it and yeah you know the only one that
doesn't end with the t-rex is the third
one which pissed off a lot of - you piss
me off you know because that's always
the best part you do something cool with
the t-rex at the end of all these
matters the worst part of Jurassic Park
3 no no but that's one of the things
it's like that's the one thing you know
that all the Year films have is they it
doesn't cool the deer and this one just
it eats the bad guy FBI again lost world
already did that
uh it's just nothing I mean it's just
like well there's the t-rex okay well we
here's our DNA oh it gets stops just
like the Barbasol can so what does that
do like well at least we stopped genetic
mutated but but you didn't because the
DNA is doping sends yeah crazy-ass clone
still works and a raptor and I'm just
like my fairness went blue like looks
amazing come on blue we'll take you
someplace safe and blue looks at the
cage it's like mm-hmm it just runs off
and Chris Pratt has this look like okay
I understand that I'm just here was like
that's great there's a velociraptor now
loose in the world that's awesome and
these these probably a
I mean how males nicer where the her
again I mean they're just loose on the
world because they're live like me fuck
you you little brat
it was a mistake to call you and again
III feel bad for that girl because she
was a pretty good actress I was like wow
is the writing on this terrible and I
just realized something
weird look she shot at the end too with
the close-up on the ice it's like she
evil like I'm like is it like an alien
resurrection yeah it's like she evil is
that what's going on here they implying
that she's the next Hammond and she's
like yeah I'm a fuck of the earth you
know here's the thing too I just brought
the Alien Resurrection bad movie but at
the very low no knows this no you want
to know what this is to me this is the
alien covenant no no no no the series oh
god that's not what's going to out
saying that at least with Alien
Resurrection is tapping with this idea
she's a clone
well you could just have her back and be
the same thing no she's kind of like got
a little be the alien DNA and issued
good guys she a bad guy it's not done
well but it's at least tempt into an
address I just realized what if that was
the focus of this movie that you know
early on that she's a clone or at least
halfway through and she's like dealing
with looking at these dinosaurs and
everything it's just like what do i as
I'm a clone too I was made from nothing
I was made from science and like these
were made from science to advice I
thought it was altered like you know
Elizabeth and BioShock Infinite or
something yeah like getting back like
they diving came back like don't that be
actually you know talk about smart
things it's like I just feel like that
would be something new that I'd be
something totally different totally new
and you can have great visuals
reflecting what the characters are going
through but no it's a line at the end
just to justify why not just get it move
she's that cloud yeah which I guess is
supposed to be like some sort of animal
rights thing but all I'm thinking is
just like oh there it is I to me that's
like
save all the animals or what I don't get
the politics of this film I don't get
the tone of this film I don't get the
science of it on the zoo because I just
got lost world in thing even though Jeff
Goldblum technically in that film is
going to save them you know but but this
one again
I guess his argument is I was saving
them so that they could live on the
island now that the islands gonna blow
them out my fuckin yeah well which again
kind of make sense and the movie
explains why this movie should but they
had had to have the animal rights people
so that they could they could trick them
and so she could say it was all ya got
if you want I've seen my sister sjw's
like just take over the castle your
movie you love this like that yeah but
the doctor that annoying ass computer
programmer I am just like oh no my view
especially you but but my favorite was
stuck asshole misogynistic military guy
versus about the broker wanna be in art
yeah stark or stock snarky sjw like type
was just like hey I'm not the delicate
little snowflake you think I am yeah
even though you're gonna be like
kidnapped throughout most of the movie
he was like I was like wow too
cartoonish stereotypes facing each other
up and I hate both of them you know and
again i feel like this is already I feel
like I feel like she was Daria if you
removed everything that made Daria
insert stare likable hit yeah ever like
it ya know Daria wouldn't you know cheap
talk about me can we get involved oh no
no and you're right because the more I
think back on the more I'm realizing
like yeah this is trying to be really
really political and it's really suck
their chest tray like it's Witter is a
nasty woman remark especially I'm just
like fucking really we're really doing
so we've got Millennials now so let's
throw some Millennials into this yeah
it's like they drew up drastic park this
is for you
Jurassic Park one is it's David only in
the technology I don't look at that feel
a lot to technology
yeah you know it but it like I look at
the production design and everything
around in outside the kind of timeline
outside of the tech yeah there's nothing
that I'm just like it's timeless I look
at this film I'm gonna be like yep that
looks like 2018 yeah which is to say it
looks like probably the early 2000
because I feel like our pop culture has
stopped somewhere after the early 2000s
like I can look at the 80s the 90s the
70s is like I swear somewhere after 2001
that's just we have not evolved pop
culture wise like doesn't it all look
the same to you it's been 18 years and
it just it all just looks the same to me
but it looks a little bland
maybe that's the type land yeah it's
only stock yeah Rock Millennials versus
stock military industrial complex guys
like there's a movie like the more I'm
thinking about even with Jurassic world
it's like - all of their credit you're
right there is kind of a timeless
element to them like you can look at
them and be like okay this probably came
out in this time period but like yeah
but the way the people reacted what they
wear and stuff like you're asking world
I wouldn't be able to tell right this
one you're just watch - just be like oh
yeah like yeah 2010's or you know or
late 2010 so you know it's like that's
when this came out like how there talk
to you look at how they're acting look
at what they're wearing well the other
two seem divorced from reality at large
because they were containing that I'm
sorry but like okay it was a funny joke
with the news ticker but I'm just like
that automatically just dates him like
well guess Trump was president like that
it's just that's such a little thing
that doesn't bother me too much
but everybody adds up after a while and
I'm like that's a shame now that we've
just decided that okay these aren't
gonna be made to be timeless they're
litora and that's what this movie is
it's a cheap cash crap i shouldn't say
cheap because it was expensive but it
just has cash grab written all over it
to me I'll say this to kind of to its
credit cuz a lot of dinosaurs do look
fake but the t-rex
or whatever and at the end was looking
okay and there's a lot of times where
I'm like thankfully I know that has to
be CG but I'm like that this looking
okay and a few for those times where
they have a real puppet there and that
always have great when they have a few
things about the movie that didn't
bother me was the dinosaurs are really
the special effects in general and was
this distracting it's the last film like
the volcano bid I'm like well okay and I
kinda good no no no but the dinosaurs
wrong yeah it's fun to sing that's like
I kind of get it under the top I'm like
stop it I mean your own movie or at
least I know when when they go into the
room with all the dinosaur bones and are
hiding behind things I'm like it's the
kitchen from yeah the frise it's just
like but the yeah I think the story was
so bad that I just the dinosaurs are one
a few things I kind of see when the
dinosaurs around the screen I don't mind
it so much is this I hate watching these
fucking humans yeah else too spoiled
that was the big one where I was like
yeah can't believe it's nuts West which
is like a clone and she destroyed us all
yeah I mean I'm alive Johnny Five is
alive yeah really looking back that it's
so flanked just the part that was like
the stupidest part of this movie the
board thinking about it should have been
the focus like her being a clone and
then trying to connect with these died
you know and especially her being a
person before that died and then brought
back with these dies or at night and
brought back that what is that
effectively the only thing I like about
this is how messed up this this family
and the Hammond family are I'm like this
is some real House of Usher shit going
on here as I sounds like turned into
some dark gothic novel or it's like
we're trapped in the mansion in there
secrets everywhere like so I'm just like
well if you want to do that fine but
it's like no it's just some rich guy
wanting to auction off dinosaurs cuz ya
knows we haven't seen that if you like
the beginning of the third act of
Atlantis the lost Empire that's last on
this movie yeah yeah you're right now
yeah I'm just I'm so sexy like Atlantis
the laws I'm being that's uh yeah that
part sucked that's like the whole move
and what this movie felt like this felt
like a movie and from 1996 yep like
that's a good way to put down like every
mark was a 1996 disaster movie right
down to the comical bad guy who
shouldn't mess with nature but oh all
the scenes in the rain with the t-rex i
automatic I was like we're in trouble
because I'm already just being reminded
of Godzilla the 1998 version of gods uh
it's not 96 I think you're talking about
98 through 2000 that era I'm talking
about Dante's big volcano yeah a little
bit but I I see Godzilla
I see a lot of Godzilla in this like
just the lameness
I can very easily see Cary Elwes in a
black van driving by you know talk about
dr. woo he's not in it for the science
anymore this is my shit for the money
can't sell some corporate spots like
Chris Pratt's it so I see you got
yourself some corporate sponsors why
does he have a southern accent and is
like I didn't like it in the other movie
either I'm like just just let him talk
normal
yeah yeah man oh it's bad I'm I am so
excited to talk about this for a minute
that comes to blu-ray uh yeah I'd say
you know and I more power to big I'm
glad he enjoyed somebody's having fun
here cuz I just know and I I always I
like it when that happens because when
I'm miserable I'm like well at least
somebody's head yeah I want somebody
have fun uh I really was just kidding so
freaking bored no and there's nothing in
this Wells gonna say nothing ethically
bad but I don't know that ending is
pretty damn awful like no no if you can
free dangerous animals who are gonna
kill a bunch of people do it it's like
that's a terrible message um unless
she's evil
who knows maybe she's the bad seed I
don't think it was going for that you
know I don't know help the dinosaurs
help the tears well now they're loose
and Jeff Dublin's like this is it this
is the end of humanity and it's just a
tease how are you trying to say resume
and welcome to Jurassic world this
franchise has been around for millions
years and if we're not careful might be
around for millions more long after
we're gone
transid Park films will go a go hey
please top go extinct
I should be looking forward to a movie
where there's dinosaurs going out
throughout somehow I knew like
instinctually I was actually psyched to
see Jurassic world I was psyched to see
lost world and I was indifferent to sing
Jurassic Park 3 but I'm like why not I
like Sam Neill I had some instinct this
time I'm like I am NOT excited to see
this the more the more they can be doing
that trailer I'm like we both have about
the same line you know if the line is
remember or it was it uh well there's
two lines one is it was alive and then
the other line is a rescue mission to go
on an island that's gonna blow up and
save dinosaurs to go wrong the worst
line yeah again put in anything and fur
1996 I'll never put that in anything
yeah anything
ironically I don't remember hearing it
in the film I remember in the trailer
although it was it was in the film oh
yeah it was in the film I heard it cuz I
cringe I'm like well it's bad but not
quite as bad as the trailer but it's
still bad yeah and then her delivery I
knew it I'll give her some credit I do
think that between the last film and
this one slowly she has gotten worse and
a minder it looks to me an acts like one
of those mocap Androids from that nudity
becoming human game I can see it like
she looks like a CGI creation to me I'm
not convinced she isn't and like in like
when she smiles like there's a couple
scenes where like she does this big
smile and hey and like it's unnatural
like in an uncanny valley sort of way
and I'm just like she's CGI because
there's something about her acting that
just she gets a lot as the film goes on
she gets better but the first third of
the film in particular is just painful
for me I I didn't know that there was a
lot of women I didn't love her I didn't
love her necessarily in the first one
either but it was such a stock just like
I am businesswomen tight like that I
just kind of look past it it's just like
yeah and she's just some crazy work all
I like but but this one where she's
having to have like emotions outside of
that I'm just like yeah this is weird
and like when she sees like it's just a
weird setup anyway maybe I was just like
whatever yeah I guess you're right the
more I think about like whenever the
music's like oh you mean that person
Karl again the house like ah but it's
like we have Kentucky Fried movie
festival again here what was dead we
feel we need a callable concentration I
I feel like I can't just connected that
to the movie though with the music and
the corniness and stuff like that like
she's giving the director what see
that's where I'm just like I'm like it's
just a comedy because that's what we you
mean that guy and I'm just like are we
in a comedy and that's see where the
Raptor was like smiling before is it -
yeah - but then at other points it's so
dark and then it's just like she's a
clone and shit and she's like I'm gonna
destroy the world and and I'm just like
what what what is going on who would
bear I can't I still can't I can't wrap
my head around I'm probably good this is
gonna be like some sort of Zen riddle
I'm gonna be thinking about for weeks
let's go round and round in my head and
I'm gonna wake up with like on the floor
with blood shooting out my nose I mean
died of an aneurysm what is Jurassic
world following Kingdom a bad I wish it
what is the sound of one movie failing
Jurassic world funky say but one big
pile of shit
you